from your experience so far
up and coming artists we talked earlier
about how sometimes uh
we talked about
that the video behind blast would cost
15 grand right that's which is a lot
right that's crazy but what are some
things that you
see artists wasting money on or maybe
getting taken advantage of that you know
whether it's
video production whether it's you know i
it annoys me when i have homies that are
up and coming artists and they're like
hey this guy hit me saying he could get
me on complex and all these blogs you
think i should do it and i'm like [ __ ]
no no
like but what are some of those things
that you know
you you kind of think artists could save
some money on or that you see them
getting
took on a little you know i see it
happening a lot so so i think
one music videos
all right like
some artists think that they got to go
pay a bag to a director and that just
because they got a bunch of bread in the
video and like a bunch of females in the
video it's gonna go right when it's like
you can really do the opposite like i
said like touch down on these college
campuses and realize like there's a
whole film department of a bunch of kids
that need work and there's probably some
out there that's actually gonna be the
next
who's who to be able to tap in with them
and get on that type of level because
it's all about recruiting from the
ground source so i feel like
in the digital
digital media space photography and
videography like
a lot of videographers get over on
artists just because they don't
understand like
the one two-step process what the
difference is and having a steadicam and
the difference between having a handheld
camera like the price difference between
all that type of stuff um i also think
pr damn they'll be dipping sometimes too
because it's like explain that because
you could have that that background and
like yeah like
public relations is pretty much like
one people need to understand in pr
they're pitching your story to people
they can't they can't guarantee anything
you can't guarantee and the same way no
label can guarantee you to be on rap
caviar right nobody can guarantee all
they can do is put you in front of the
people and hopefully the the person
who is pitching you has a good enough
relationship to where they're gonna
accept so that's what that is like right
like it's not it don't matter
about if you pay 5000 to the pr you may
get three [ __ ] pickups it's about the
product that's on there so i'll be
telling people all the time like you
don't need a pr if you do not have the
demand for pr right now like i
understand you want to service some
music out there but that's what you got
google adwords facebook marketing sprint
you got all that type of stuff to be
able to
do back-end marketing for people to
actually get to be able to see it
because most of the times [ __ ]
aren't reading articles know it yeah i
think that the most like overrated [ __ ]
is like
you know back in the day
[Music]
your life might get changed if you ended
up on uh
complex or two dope boys or whatever
blog right but like hip-hop yeah
whatever it is right but nowadays it's
like
we're not even consuming like
media that way anymore like
unfortunately you know obviously those
sites are still very you know they they
produce dope content they do dope things
but like you know there used to be a
time when if you got one of those looks
it would matter
yeah but it would move the needle but it
doesn't move the needle anymore it
doesn't because streaming platforms took
they pretty much their essence away
because if you take if you take five
grand and give it to a pr person to get
on these websites it's like you might as
well you should have took in that five
grand to shop five videos yeah for sure
me personally i look at
pr as like
just momentum pushes i don't even think
them articles really be that important
but what i think it is is
yeah it's for your consumer to see like
oh he looks like he's bubbling up right
now oh he got a double looks like
re-information yeah yeah just a bomb to
drop just to be like keep your momentum
going in but to keep the the channel
noisy as they say in journalism like
keep the fans almost excited like oh
yeah this [ __ ] is going yeah it is kind
of crazy because if fans think or see
certain things it makes them want to
[ __ ] with you even more even though that
they're like i've noticed that well it's
like sigmund freud the power of the
subconscious like you're playing
somebody mental so much and you you
present something that's instagram at
the end of the day like you present one
thing to them so much they gonna start
to take that in and really like
associate that with you regardless of if
you telling them that or actually like
just giving them a visual
of that [ __ ] it's going to go the way
you want it to go if you if you
consistently because nowadays right
there's like uh our generation now
what's it called
there's like all these ig pages that
people pay to get on right yeah and like
you'll see the ones you know
that are like
like okay this guy's paid for that look
right and and now unfortunately with
some of these pages it's like almost
most of them you could tell are like the
label drop in the bag so would you say
worldstar started that though for sure
because worldstar pretty much started
that whole business model right yeah no
for sure
posted and then
but see worldstar used to really like
damn near
i don't think people was understanding
like what like google owned youtube and
all that [ __ ] so i don't think they
understood like
world star was just taking a personal
money you paid anyway and just putting
it behind the ads and [ __ ] like that so
that's why i was picking up so many
views but
again it's the difference between people
looking at the system from
the broad perspective or looking at it
from like a functionality perspective